I max is about delivering an experience
that you cannot replicate anywhere else
except in an IMAX cinema and its best
when it's actually filmed with an IMAX
camera Chris is someone who honors that
and who forces us to ask those questions
of why aren't we doing it this way more
frequently
the camera department had to take a very
experimental approach to the way we want
to shoot the film with the IMAX cameras
we wanted a lot of handheld camera we
won't do a lot of camera mounts we
actually mounted on on helmets we
mounted in space as we mounted on bodies
really treating an IMAX camera like a
GoPro camera people said you could never
handheld an IMAX camera well he
certainly proved that is a fallacy the
movies opening two days early and film
only theaters of which we have gone back
to our legacy in history with the way
we're handling the film theaters we
began the process eighteen months ago
before principal photography talking to
those theaters that were converting over
from film to digital we said please hold
onto that projector you can't take that
projector out of here we're gonna
probably need that in the future we put
in rail systems for them so that they
can keep their digital systems in place
for some of the other product that
they're playing but they can also move
their film projector into the prime
position and be ready for this round of
interstellar and we've really worked
hard for over a year to make sure that
this is is going to be the vision that
Chris Nolan has for his film in IMAX the
print of interstellar is 49 reals weighs
about 600 pounds on a 72 inch platter
it's a thing to behold it's in the
situation where we're sending out
assembled prints it takes three cases
with three plotters inside and then a
projectionist on the other end we'll put
those thirds together to make that same
print we take no chances with a movie
like this there will be a lot of people
in the field that are gonna be taking
care of making sure those projections
are good the clock behind me shows how
many days till the launch that is not
the end of it for us the reality is is
we're geared up we're ready so that in
those first four weeks of the release of
this picture we have got a tight team
ready to go
nothing can beat an IMAX capture a film
has got full bandwidth in all those
colors and Chris calls it the gold
standard and it absolutely is we care
about the quality of our presentation
and we work with no filmmaker who makes
us better more than Chris Nolan t-minus
three when you see the picture in IMAX
you will have that feeling that you're
never gonna see it quite the same way
ever again - do not go gentle into that
good night old age should burn and rave
at close of day one rage rage against
the dying of the light
here we go